à quelques années et quelques années ma
grand mère m'a demandé dix mois mon
petit bonhomme qu'est ce que c'est sale
internet
alors j'ai pas commencé à lui expliquer
comment fonctionnait le http protocole
qui permet qu'internet fonctionne
au lieu de cela je le dis c'est comme
une révolution au service de la
connaissance comme une immense
bibliothèque avec tout le savoir deux
mondes la même manière aujourd'hui
voudraient vous expliquer pourquoi la
machine pourrait être potentiellement
une révolution au service de la
coopération
là vous permettent de coopérer avec des
inconnus en toute confiance alors qu'est
ce que la bloque chain on pourrait
imaginer que le bloc chaîne fait comme
un livre un livre dont nom porte qui
pourrait avoir une copie lorsque vous
écrivez dans ce livre fait
automatiquement recopié dans tous les
accus et lorsque vous écrivez dans ce
livre le stylo avec lequel vous écrivez
à une couleur unique de tels fortes ont
fait instantanément pied et en sang
lorsque vous écrivez dans ce livre c'est
écrit à jamais il est impossible de
dépasser ce qui a été écrit alors
concrètement à quoi pourrait servir un
tel livre prenons un exemple simple un
peu caricatural
admettons quelqu'un frenchies offrir sa
maison pourquoi pas il pourrait écrire
dans ce livre simplement qu'il vous
offre sa maison tout le monde pourrait
voir cette information
tout le monde pourrait vérifier qu'il
s'agit bien de de la personne qui a
écrit ça
couleurs de son stylo et en cela il ne
pourrait à aucun moment revenir en
arrière
on voit ici que malgré le fait que c'est
peut-être un inconnu
malgré ça que vous lui fassiez pas
confiance et bien pour autant le système
permet d'assurer que cette maison est
bien la nôtre et autres éléments clés on
voit ici même si fait un exemple un peu
simpliste que l'un des rôles clés du
notaire qui consiste à fertiliser qu'un
échange a bien eu lieu n'est plus ici
nécessaire donc certaines aux yeux bien
sûr le notaire reste utile le notaire un
rôle-conseil très important mais sur
cette spécificité ne certifie qu une
transaction et dans les lieux qu'un
contrat a été respectée et bien le
notaire n'est plus indispensable
alors pour comprendre pourquoi la blocs
tiennent peut-être une révolution au
service de la coopération
je vous propose de revenir un peu en
arrière prenons une tribu une tribune
dans laquelle les gens caubère les uns
avec les autres
il faut mettre d'accord de manière
informelle pour pouvoir s'échanger des
biens pour pouvoir prendre des décisions
pour pouvoir permettre cette coopération
il ya un élément fondamental c'est le
cercles de confiance les gens dans cette
tribu se font confiance
et si à tout moment quelqu'un ne
respectent pas les règles de l'est
change les règles de la coopération
qu'ont été mis en place eh bien ils
risquent d'être exclus de sa marque de
confiance ils risquent d'être exclus des
tribus l'avantagent majeur de ce type de
coopération basé sur la confiance est
basée sur des règles mis en place de
manière informelle et bien fait que on
peut très rapidement de manière très
agile simplement en en discutant avec la
personne avec qui en colère
on peut très facilement mettre mettre à
jour les règles qui nous permette de
corée l'inconvénient c'est que d'appel
d'après robin dunbar qui est un
sociologue l'humain et cognitivement est
biologiquement incapable de créer des
cercles de confiance de plus de 150
personnes en moyenne est passée ce
chiffre passe à ce nombre
la confiance s'étiole et alors il
devient beaucoup plus compliqué de
coopérer il devient plus compliqué de
coopérer et ce chiffre de 150 personnes
il est il a été visible à travers
l'histoire
c'est le nombre de personnes qu'ils
avaient en moyenne dans les villages
fermiers au néolithique et encore
aujourd'hui
lorsque vous êtes sur facebook c'est le
nombre moyen de maximum de personnes
avec qui vous avez des réellement des
interactions alors pour faire face à
cette limite la civilisation s'est
structuré petit à petit et la formaliser
les règles qui nous permette de coopérer
il a mis en place des lois des normes
des règlements et en plus de ça elle a
mis en place des intermédiaires ces
intermédiaires que sont les les
organisations qui fâchent furent que les
règles les lois les normes soient
respectées et qui nous permette que
malgré ça qu'on n'ait pas conscience
dans une personne avec qui l'on souhaite
coopérer par le biais de cet
intermédiaire nous pouvons coopérer en
toute confiance
c'est loin d'être anodin
nous sommes la seule espèce au monde
d'après nos connaissances capables de
coopérer à l'échelle mondiale entre
inconnus
c'est pas rien l'inconvénient de ce
mode de coopération n'avait sur les
intermédiaires et la formalisation des
règles de coopération l'inconvénient
c'est que nous sommes beaucoup moins
vasile beaucoup moins flexibles pour
remettre en cause ces normes promettre
en cause ces règles on peut le voir par
exemple dans une entreprise vous arrivez
dans l'entreprise vous signez votre
contrat de travail et éventuellement
quelques modifications vous pouvez faire
mais globalement le contrat de travail
est similaire quel que soit le le
collaborateur et vous pouvez pas non
plus changer ce contrat les modalités ce
contrat
toutes les semaines parce que là vous
êtes un peu moins fort nous parce que là
vous ne vous sentez plein d'énergie donc
un problème de flexibilité et d'agilité
et un deuxième problème
une question qu'on peut se poser c'est
que est ce qu'aujourd'hui la confiance
que l'on porte envers cet intermédiaire
n'est pas en train de s'étioler
en 2008 par exemple avec la crise des
subprimes une partie de la population et
elle est dans la rue pour challenge et
les banques sur leur manière de gérer
l'économie
c'est d'ailleurs suite ou durant cette
fête
ce challenge vis-à-vis des banques tiéné
la blog team
c'est dans ce contexte plus récemment
devant la coop 24 une jeune lycéenne
s'est présenté face au leader à nos
leaders pour venir les challengers sur
leur capacité à gérer les crises en
cours et à venir
parlons un peu de ces crimes
on parle de crise climatique
effectivement mais aussi de crise
démographique la population de la
population mondiale n'a été n'a jamais
été aussi importante avec une croissance
exponentielle
on parle d'eux
politique on parle de crise sociale de
crise potentiellement économique et
beaucoup dexter famille pour dire que
ces crimes ne sont que les prémices de
tempête bien plus grande va venir nous
sommes potentiellement à l'aube d'un
changement de civilisation que l'on soit
uni et pour pouvoir opérer ce changement
pour pouvoir nous adapter
il va en effet faire de changer le
système et pour pouvoir changer le
système il va nous falloir coopérer à
l'échelle mondiale entre inconnus mais
aussi une manière très agile de manière
très flexible et sans la contrainte des
conflits d'intérêts eh bien ça tombe
bien parce que la bloque chez nous
permet propose quelques axes de
solutions concrètement admettons que
l'on souhaitons que nous souhaitions
collaborer coopérer pardon à l'échelle
mondiale il va nous falloir nous mettre
d'accord sur quels fonds des faits sur
qu'est ce qui est vrai et ensuite il va
nous falloir agir
il va nous falloir prendre des décisions
il va nous falloir investir et que
j'étais là pendant ces quatre exemples
déjà avoir accès à l'information
lorsque vous mangez intec pouvoir savoir
d'où vient ce steak est déjà quelque
chose qui n'est pas tâche facile
aujourd'hui
graff à la blog team
on peut tout à fait imaginer que danse
libre le pêcheur lorsqu'il pêche tous
poissons écrivent qu'il a pêché un
boissons et lui donne un nom à mon
unique et que tout au long de la chaîne
de production
lorsque je bois sont passe de main en
main lorsque les gens transforment ce
poisson est bien ce soit ce soit écrit
dans la blue jam dans ce livre tout le
monde aurait accès à l'information la
blog chaîne novethic propose justement
de permettre cette traçabilité de
l'alimentation et de la même manière la
blog team trg affaires propose la
traçabilité des diamants une fois que
nous avons un peu de visibilité sur ces
informations là encore faut-il être sûr
qu'elles soient vraies et ici nous
pouvons imaginer encore de reprendre ce
livre lorsque quelqu'un écrit quelque
chose moines d'un fait et bien nous
pourrions chacun venir confirmer lorsque
nous avons nous même été témoin de cet
événement vous me direz c'est quelque
chose qu'aujourd'hui on peut déjà faire
on peut très bien mettre les effets sur
internet et puis chacun peut venir voter
pour des ruiz était là la différence
c'est que ici il n'ya pas d'organe il
n'y a pas d'organisme qui gère ces
données personne n'a la main sur ces
données si nous avions une organisation
qui qui a été capable de gérer ses
données
de dire qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est-ce
qu il est faux finalement elle se ferait
fortement challenger ou bien elle aurait
un pouvoir démesuré et si l'as blotzheim
tribe propose justement de pouvoir venir
valider des informations pour écouter
les techniques l'échec news comme celle
du président trump qui dit que le
réchauffement climatique est une fête
news
une fois que nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sur quelle est la situation
actuelle est bien nous pouvons commencer
à agir
nous pouvons prendre des décisions
prendre des décisions il ya plusieurs
modalités possibles
prenons l'exemple du vote aujourd'hui
mettre en place un vote dans notre
société c'est très lourd ça demande
beaucoup de mises en place et en plus de
ça nous ne sommes même pas sûrs que les
actions soient mis en place derrière un
référendum et en plus de ça fait souvent
réduit à un pays graff a democracy earth
nous pouvons utiliser la bloque tiennent
pour pouvoir voter directement dans ce
grenier qui permet finalement une
démocratie beaucoup plus direct
démocratie beaucoup plus liquide et en
plus de cela
ça permet de pouvoir prendre des
décisions à l'échelle mondiale ensemble
nous fois que nous souhaitons que nous
avons pris les décisions
il peut être nécessaire d'investir et
non pas d'investir dans le but de faire
du profit mais dans le but de s'assurer
que la planète reste stable ou
s'améliore ici
la black sun energy networks propose à
plusieurs acteurs de pouvoir investir
dans un néo lyonnais
là encore vous me direz on peut très
bien investir à plusieurs dans une
éolienne
mais grâce à des blocs saigne nous
allons être beaucoup plus flexibles et
vous allez pouvoir investir au prorata
de votre consommation au prorata de
votre besoin et faire évoluer votre
investissement au quotidien
voilà c'était donc quatre petits
exemples il y en a beaucoup d'autres
l'idée était simplement de partager avec
vous comment nous pouvons coopérer
aujourd'hui différemment et comment
potentiellement cela va être un effet
faire dans les années à venir
nous avons un changement de civilisation
à faire tous ensemble et ce changement
passera par nous aider aujourd'hui il
reste beaucoup de choses à faire pour
que l'âme l'obtiennent permettent de
charges tout cela il ya énormément de
recherche et développement depuis dix
ans et ne rêve que de l'autre côté de la
rue il ya la bloque ian davey qui
propose de gérer les commandes
et comme tout bloc chaîne elle est
décentralisée et nous pouvons tous venir
apporter notre pierre à l'édifice
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]